I was actually timing my heartbeat I'm
making something's about to go wrong
here your heart maybe my heartbeat hits
about 150 something wrong
these aren't laced with em feta means
are they no now hey what's going on
everybody for first we feast I'm Sean
Evans and you're watching hot ones it's
the show with hot questions and even
hotter wings and today we closed out
season 9 with Stone Cold Steve Austin
he's a six-time WWF World Heavyweight
Champion and WWE Hall of Famer you can
catch him on the award-winning podcast
the Steve Austin show and he also has a
new TV show it's called straight-up
Steve Austin ketchup Monday is 11:10
central after Monday Night Raw on the
USA Network stone cold welcome to the
show glad to be here man it's gonna be a
hell of an extravaganza I don't know
what I've just got myself into but I'm
ready to go with you well I know that
you're in Edna Texas boy how do you
handle your spice man in my environment
back in the day I was a toughest sob in
the history of the WWE here in front of
you I might be the biggest [ __ ] you've
ever had on the show that remains to be
seen and that's what we're about to find
out
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh sorry owner
[Music]
but yes good
so as a show that forces scorching hot
chicken wings on our guests were super
interested in this movement towards
experiential celebrity interviews do you
think all those years clicking with
wrestlers in the ring do you think that
gives you an advantage when it comes to
building chemistry with a TV show or
podcast guests no miss stone cold steve
austin back in the day a lot of people
think guys a little bit wound up he's a
little bit over their heads he's crazy
you know he's always mad he drinks a lot
I drink a little bit but uh III enjoy
meeting people I enjoy talking people in
and I'm curious by nature the more you
do something the better you get at it so
I'm hoping this season catches on so I
can apply what I've learned this season
into another season and to keep doing
keep going from there but I don't I
don't think being at W Superstar
necessarily you know made me a natural
at it
[Music]
I like the gradual kind of none of you
we've got several to go here I like what
you're doing here after I know that
there's a method to your madness and
I've enjoyed watching the shows that
I've watched oh thank you you've seen it
so you do kind of know what you're
getting yourself into here absolutely so
being a global icon in a national
treasure the mythology around Stone Cold
Steve Austin it's so vast so I think
that it's only right early on in the
interview that we clear the air on some
of the lore surrounding the Texas
rattlesnake factor fiction before you
decided on stone cold the WWF gave you a
list of possible nicknames that included
fang mcfist chile mick freeze and otto
von ruthless true this is way back in
the day I was living on 10 acres at a
log cabin out South Georgia and I was
watching a special on HBO about richard
kuklinski it was a serial killer he was
a hit man and I'm not endorsing anything
he did but he was this ruthless
individual so I said okay there's some
trace there that would make a good
villain in the squared circle so I
pitched the idea to the office and the
Iceman had already been done at a local
level down in Dallas my iceman king
parsons so we didn't want to go down
that road and so based on you know the
my concept that I gave them they pitched
me temperature base names it wasn't
about being temperature based it's cold
blooded you know like mean remorseless
ruthless and so I was like you got to be
kidding me this is a creative genius as
WWE I mean they're supposed to make
anybody and everybody and turn them into
a superstar so the names were absolutely
ridiculous and I could not believe that
that was the best that they came up with
is there any truth to the rumor that a
hundred plus beers were consumed during
that beer bash in Japan with Stacy
Keibler and the Dudley's that is true
now actually all the way consumed twelve
ounce portions I don't know but spilled
I had heard about 128 I don't think it's
still a record but you come out of a
session like that and like people say
hey man you wasted most that damn beer
I've got to show best part of it if I
was just a sip at all and just drinking
all it'd be a horrible visual so you got
to get some on you but I'll tell
there's been I don't know how many times
I would come out of that ring and you
leave with the bus yeah you going empty
belly and it goes with all that beer
you're gonna get a bus factor fiction
you and Booker T cause $10,000 worth of
damage to a grocery store brawling that
is indeed what I heard the total damage
was I believe that was called the green
frog I think I was in Fresno California
if I'm not mistaken I think the store
closed down after there's nothing not
because of that but after that and we
had an absolute blast Booker and I have
always had a chemistry going back from
our days in Atlanta when we both worked
for WCW
he's one of the funniest guys I know and
I just had him on my podcast as a matter
of fact but yeah $10,000 where the
damage was the sum total factor fiction
you'll let the caboose loose while
wrestling Yokozuna in South Africa had
to yeah a lot of times when you do
international tribes when you do an
international travel and there's a
dietary chain the cakes happen and
manioc man he was weighing you know 600
evil pounds at the time and when he
picked me up and slammed me things
happened something went south and
luckily I was wearing black trunks and
yoga was so cool he's no longer with us
and God rest his soul but I was laying
there on the mat I just crapped my
trunks and I looked at him I said yo
let's go home go home is Russell speak
for her let's do the finishing get out
of here and he's so cool he goes okay
brah and we did the finish I got meat
and I walked to the back and took a hell
of a shower
[Music]
chiquan dhis i don't want to be level
three to be the one that makes me have a
Yokozuna moment here on your show
there's a seeds finale but what a finish
it would be yes don't go out and he [ __ ]
himself
what's our language parameters you can
go stone-cold unleashed here okay okay I
don't want to go crazy this is starting
to get a little out there I know that
you're a driver's ed teacher as a senior
at North Texas do you have a biggest
driving pet peeve people don't use the
blinkers number one use your effing
blinkers please I mean you know it it's
like if someone's it's someone's driving
a car it's real bad shape you think okay
what you know [ __ ] the blinkers just
broke are that the you know the light
doesn't work but then if it's someone in
a real nice car like a Mercedes or BMW I
was just an [ __ ] he thinks he's
entitled it needs hitting that uses
blinkers but that's my number one pet
peeve use your effing blinkers please
and then do you still have a problem
with rats on the ranch and know for a
while there they were chewing up your
Chevy trucks and Polaris Rangers there
were a severe problem we never defeated
them
I sold the ranch about three years ago
and we're now based out of Nevada
of course I'm now fortunate enough to be
driving Kawasaki mules and they don't
touch my mules because there's not as
many up there for some reason and we
have a bunch of cats anybody in South
Texas or in the remote areas you know
are dealing with rats and they're a real
problem you go out there to fire up your
car sometimes it won't fire your lights
don't fire so you always keep the hood
up you know you put steel wool in your
tailpipes you do the things you can do
best thing is by cats the pro tips from
Stone Cold Steve Austin are you're ready
to move on to number four yeah you
reading me Emma
and your eyes I can see it look anyway
boy you do to stay there while he's
taking a bite out of these wings and say
it's first rodeo there's gonna be the
one that gets me
so I know that you're a true student of
professional wrestling and you're always
very generous with your praise for those
who've come before you and after pound
for pound who was the most physically
impressive athlete during your wrestling
days hmm
dad my kid back in his day was very
cutting edge just a snap suplex is
diving off the top ropes I mean he was
really innovative the way he did things
we he executed things in a ring he would
be someone that I would put on a list
that I highly respected besides herself
who had the best mic skills during the
Attitude Era
you can not overlook the rock when he
first arrived on the scene he was this
good-looking you know third generation
babyface and just people just didn't
take to him and it was a dire akhi die
die rocky dining put him in the nation
of domination and he has sent it to the
top of that organization and he started
wearing this the silk shirts and he
started referring to himself in third
person and working out eyebrow and he
electrified and captivated crowds with
his catchphrases his cadence and his
delivery and his message and called
everybody to brony knowing your role so
yes I was an outstanding promo in my own
right and had my own style but Rock
commanded the audience's respect
attention and it elicited the response
that he was looking for from them who
had the most insane pre-match ritual I
don't know who had the most insane but
who had this simplest was Jake the snake
Roberts because it's back in the day
when he carried the snake and the bag
that the snake would be laying on say a
trash can with a flat top or maybe on
the floor and Jake would it be walking
around he never went to the gym and he'd
be smoking a cigarette and all of a
sudden they'd hit next music he'd take a
final drag off that cigarette crush it
out with his foot throw the snake over
his back and just walk to the ring no
warm-up no nothing that's how he did it
dragging on a cigarette and once Jake
got in the ring he commanded your
respect and he had this presence about
him and he's one of the most economic
efficient workers out there where he
didn't do a whole lot but
everything he did had meant something
and he was always working for that DDT
so he was phenomenal in that right but
the simplicity of his warm-up routine
would stand out more than the craziest
routine that I can think of all right so
Nicole we have a recurring segment on
our show called explain that Graham
where we do a deep dive on I guess
Instagram pull interesting pictures that
need more context so I'll bust out the
laptop I'll show you the picture you
just tell me the bigger story does that
sound good yep all right
[Music]
here you are doing some work on the
ranch in all your years and ranching
have you ever flipped a tractor been
bitten by a snake when you think about
broken skull and the near emergencies is
there a story that stands out there's a
couple times when we're mowing the ponds
we would call them tanks in Texas a
waterhole the the embankments are pretty
damn steep and I used to work for the
highway department when I was a kid you
know so I'm used to driving on the
overpasses and stuff like that Mon the
size of highways but there's there's a
kind of a pucker factor we'd call it and
you're dragging a 15-foot batwing
shredder behind you which kind of gives
you a little bit of a low center of
gravity here keeps you anchored to the
ground but just the fact that if you hit
a hog Waller or something like that you
just know that that tractors going to
flip over and your answer is going to be
upside down in the water and ain't
nobody gonna get you out of there so
many many near cases of that or just
pucker factor never got bit by
rattlesnake I heard a few and they have
a very distinct rattle when you're
walking to your deer stand and all of a
sudden one starts rattling at units that
come back that come to Jesus moment and
I don't hear very well but then you can
hear that I could hear damn rattlesnake
you know like like it's nobody's
business what do you remember about
meeting Muhammad Ali Paul Orndorff is a
guy right there to look to the left side
of that picture he actually took a pair
of boxing gloves to get Muhammad Ali to
sign them
but Muhammad Ali was simply the greatest
boxer that ever lived in such a
charismatic personality that he had this
global worldwide following of people who
absolutely loved him I've never met
anybody that said anything bad about
Muhammad Ali because he was just
universally loved by literally everyone
so it was really cool to remember that I
met the goat sip of tequila for the
working man do you have a go-to
margarita recipe oh yeah so basically
I'm working with a 3-ounce shot glass
got it I go patron silver just because
you can go a higher-grade tequila that's
gonna be a lot smoother but you're gonna
need a little bit of bite in that
margarita
so three ounces of tequila I may pour
this in a shaker about an ounce to an
ounce and a half
of triple sec about an ounce to ounce in
a quarter of lime juice people get
carried away with lime juice most time
when you go to restaurants and you give
it something that just tastes like lime
a and it just kills you no can do that's
the biggest mistake rookies make or
bartenders there's no no there [ __ ] with
the margarita just a spray of a ghave
nectar just a few drops so you shake
that up in a shaker right and then you
pour it out on fresh rocks and then you
float about an ounce of Grand Marnier on
top and that's the brothers go Rance
margarita and each one you drink is a
triple so by the time you drink two of
my margaritas that's tequila you're good
yeah now I'm not good but but you would
be good heating up mmm so when you're
chatting with Hulk Hogan on your podcast
recently you guys were talking about
wrestling and Japan and how crazy it was
in the 70s why does that era why does
that scene
why does that have such a special place
and wrestling insiders hearts just going
back to the old Japan days that's when
it was really kind of still considered a
shoot you know welcome back to the
dressing Oh many times you're like in
Kansas City a Harley Race you know there
there's guys you know stories of guys
getting stabbed and gaff you know my
knives from fans because they were so
you know bought into the fact of what
they were saying if the heels were
getting heat or you know beating up done
and the good guys and they really cared
about those good guys hell man a lot of
times those bad guys had to fight their
way to the dressing room and so that's
but it's those old Japan days memories
like that that harken up those fond
memories of what the business really was
in its core what were the fans in osaka
like compared to say a sold-out crowd at
the dallas/fort areum if you work in
front of a Japan crowd and you're from
the states they're very they're very
quiet and certain things make them come
or fire up differently than a stateside
crowd would be so like maybe these two
guys work and it's complete silence and
one of them as a submission hold on the
other one
and that one guy gets to the ropes or
they'll start to pop for that or if a
guy's starting to get just kind of
shelled on then all of a sudden he just
comes up with this fire and starts you
know responding that gets that crowd so
much different from an from an audible
level of storytelling by listening to
the crowd I don't hear very well but
once you put me in an arena full of
20,000 people
if the sumbitch up there Row 100 booing
and everybody else is sharing I know
exactly where he's at and I and I'm not
I'm not worried about him but I'm just
saying that's how in tuned I am with the
crowd because you're always reading a
crowd whether you're going by the script
that everybody talks and is talking
about or you're calling it on the fly
you're listening to that crowd because
if you're not working that crowd you're
doing it wrong hell I want shad come
over here and boy he was sweating
bullets and Gordon Ramsay was dropping
f-bombs everywhere and look at you well
like I said I think I there was a setup
here if those guys cuz III haven't got a
chance I'd love to be Gordon Ramsay I
met you five times but Shaq was really
but he said he wasn't gonna show him
faces he did pretty good he maintained
his composure for a while he started
sweaty
[Music]
it's like people they gonna say
something profound here
I was actually time in my heartbeat I'm
making something's about to go wrong
here
your heart maybe my heartbeat hits about
a hundred and fifty something wrong
these aren't laced with them feta means
all they know now yeah I'm totally dry
I'm checking my biological and
physiological responses as you're
sitting there looking at we've got them
hooked up to the biometrics over you
okay uh yeah that was starting to get
there yeah yeah that was starting to get
there I know I can go one deeper but now
would I'm feeling that one mm-hmm yeah
what you got for me
so as a guy who embraces the simple
pleasures but also has an appreciation
for the things that are badass I know
that you're very proud of the project
you've done with El Segundo Brewing
Company broken skull IPA are you of the
belief that the beer you drink says
something about the person yes it does
and I stand by that beer I worked on
that beer sitting at table just like
this very much like this with Rob crock
saw the owner of El Segundo Brewing
Company and we decided to collaborate on
a beer we had 10 to 15 beers on the
table that we both liked and/or fancied
or had some quality to them
and so as we were drinking these beers I
would explain to him and I don't really
necessarily speak beer terminology but
I'm a pretty good expert at drinking
beer and I would explain ok this is
hitting me admit I like some a little
bit more mid palate some of them hit you
to to up front or some linger too long
some are to better and I would explain
the way each beer affected me or where
resonated with me on my taste buds and I
was so proud to be down there in Tampa
at their raw reunion and I got a good
buzz and I was proud to be drinking my
frickin beer after all these years of
drinking everybody else's
don't want to do this for the people for
Season nine more by the sales pitch
never heard one we we got a do it we got
yo we're in it together we're in this
Duvall Jesus you should have been a
wrestling promoter I would love to do
that
oh my damn nose is running I even got it
close to my mouth yes Isaac oh man my
learned it I'll do it
got to
[Music]
I've shown my rage here anybody just
take a bite out of his leg
no but you know what I wouldn't ask you
something sure I'm kidding you I'm just
[ __ ] right here time in my heart right
mm-hmm
you ever had anybody come by anytime
heart rate they're the first one yeah
I'm 90 Seasons deep mattress I'm Rudy
some people call me [ __ ] up I like to
say unique it sound better so one of my
favorite things about listening to the
Steve Austin show is hearing you and
other wrestlers talk shop and trade war
stories from your years in the business
and I've come to figure out that
wrestling lingo is the best kind of
lingo what does color mean what does
cheap cheapy it is if you and me a
working imagine I'm the bad guy and I
would have spent on you but that's
cheapy because anybody could have done
that what do you mean when you say
calling high spots say a high spot is
you know now we need some motion we need
to do something to elicit response
tackle drop down hip toss if I have you
know headlock you're gonna shoot me off
you're gonna take the tackle I'm gonna
run a ropes you'll drop down i'ma jump
over you and then you're gonna hip toss
me on the way back so a high spot is
movement within the match what's the
receipt a receipt is I'll give you a
great story if you lay something in too
hard then the other person has got to
send you receive this as they dude
settle down sit away a long time ago I
was working with the big bossman ray
trailer ray travels about six six three
hundred pounds he was a farmer you know
prison guard and that was his gimmick
big boss man and Ray hit me with about
six left's you know and referee Earl
Hebner kind of sitting there watch and
he's kind of got that shit-eating grin
on his face he's kind of smiling because
he knows I'm only gonna take a few more
so finally I decided I've had enough so
I picked up ray and getting raised six
six about 300 some odd pounds
I sent him into the ropes and I told him
I said watch a clothesline so when I
tell the guy watch the clothesline
normally you're gonna hit a guy right
here you don't hit him in an Adam's
apple you just want to hit him here with
enough force so through through his axis
a pivot point he can take his bump and
land on his back here comes ray six six
well I decided you know this was a
receipt I'm not gonna give him a
clothesline
what I did I balled up my fist like that
with my form and as he was coming I
would say em I hit him right between
eyes at my form with everything I had
and big ray went down and he's on his
hands and knees and those hands is on
his knees he's damn near as tall as I am
and but he looked up at me like this and
there's almost like a Saturday morning
cartoon where stars going around as a
head like s and he has it's modeled his
face because he knew he [ __ ] up and he
goes okay and he was recognized in the
fact that I gave him a receipt and he
didn't T off on me for the rest of the
night
all right stone cold hold on goddamn
heart rates about 130
[Music]
I'm still in a safe zone I should have
wore my heartrate monitor
tell me about this one this is the
chocolate plague from pucker but pepper
company see did you need to know all
that well I did it tells me what's gonna
happen tomorrow okay I was trying to
give him a receipt story and that
sumbitch was kicking my ass
I gave you a rout I tell that story in a
much better fashion but my mouth was on
fire so I didn't get there that's great
it is milk my friend at this point most
of French sipping milk for the working
man is this gonna be hot or nothing so
much I just hate it well now you're such
a liar I wouldn't lie to you I'd be an
idiot to lie to you in this situation
but is is you're gonna compound the fact
that I've got a residual this building I
think that we're already past the point
of no return you know it's like we've
we've been drenched in a shower who
cares if it rains you're so full of [ __ ]
it's unbelievable I'm buying it I'm
going with you I know I shouldn't but
I'm going to I'm not I'm not a hot
person
could have fooled me you're doing great
[Music]
do you have a favorite WWE bra cameo
from a non wrestler the Mike Tyson stuff
was always very compelling I love doing
business Mike when he came down and
Vince McMahon introduced him a long time
ago in the middle of the ring and he was
gonna referee the match between myself
at Shawn Michaels in Russell 814 and I
came down there and got in his face
flipped him off and he pushed me and I
tried to get back at him and I was
trying as we would say going back to
wrestling go for a shoot to get back at
him of course I did one want to get back
at him but it had to look real and it
was but when he pushed me
all of these hundred-dollar bills just
flew out of his suit if you go back on
YouTube watch it and you'll watch all of
his handlers down on hands and knees
picking up hundred-dollar bills and I'm
kicking and scratching in Brisco
slaughter all the guys are holding me
back but work with Mike Tyson because
there's such a fan of the business and a
historian of the business and he
actually probably knew more about the
history of the business and a lot of
guys that were backstage might just him
him by himself as a person I just love
the guy all right stone cold Oh
[Music]
this is the last dab we call it the last
dab because it's tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last wing
you don't have to if you don't want to
follow the way just toss it up to me so
I can eat their puss out or go down
swinging with you you sorry son of a
[ __ ] tell me what I'm about to give us
help into well it's described death to
me tell me what I'm about to get myself
into Grim Reaper here's I'm saying I
think that you have gone you know we're
approaching the peak you know of this
spice mountain that were climbing
together yes and I don't see a drop of
sweat on you you know I've stared across
this table for so many crazy things from
people doing laps to spitting in buckets
to pouring milk up their nose to dumping
water over their head and you were just
calm cool and collected telling amazing
wrestling stories and pound in chicken
it's it's absolutely a sight to behold
and it's a lovely segue to this last
question okay what is it first we feast
there you go better remove
oh you wanna do this together yeah sure
sure Steve all right Stone Cold Steve
Austin here we are at the end of our
tag-team match against the wings of
death but before we go just one more
finishing move before they hit the bell
I know that you take a lot of pride in
your ability to cut a promo and for good
reason
you're one of the best who's ever done
it and then that Austin 3:16 it's still
a household catchphrase some 25 years
later so with that in mind I'm curious
what is your message to the people out
there including some on your old team
who thought that you'd get suplex today
by the wings of death i watch Gordon
Ramsay I watched Shaq and those guys
were sweating bullets and cussing and
raising all kinds of hell so for me to
be able to wing this no pun intended
have a wonderful sit-down conversation
with you who obviously does a shitload
of research was one of the defining
moments of my entire life
Wow well I am humbled beer me Chris
[Music]
a toast to season nine and to you Stone
Cold Steve Austin thank you for having
me on your show and congratulate seasons
I hope I can be a man out of straight-up
Steve Austin well now you know what
Steve there's nothing left to do but
roll out the red carpet for you my
friend this camera this camera this
camera let the people know what you have
going on in your life
hey everybody I'm Stone Cold Steve
Austin I'm sit here with Sean I just got
finished doing the season finale of hot
woods and I had a blast doing it
my mouth is on fire I got a podcast they
dropped twice a week on podcast wood and
iTunes and whatever major podcast
platforms there are I'm also got a
badass beer out called Steve Austin's
broken skull APA and right now August
12th was the season premiere for
straight-up Steve Austin my show on USA
Network it is every Monday night after
Monday Night Raw and I hope you will
tune in set your DVRs because I love
doing this show so much I'd love to be
able to be as successful as you are and
get 9 plus seasons out of it I've had a
good time here and that's the bottom
line because I said so
[Music]
great I'm Steve great job thank you man
[Music]
you
you
[Music]
you
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is Sean Evans checking in with a very
exciting hot sauce update our first ever
collaborative sauce it's here
88 rising first we feast joining forces
to make dragon in the clouds
you saw me Joe G and rich Brian mixing
it up in the cauldron yuzu from Japan
etc I'm peppercorn from China and of
course you know your boy brought the
heat but don't worry we got some
professionals together to make sure this
stuff is FDA approved extremely limited
very quality and something what we're
super proud of if you want to get your
hands on dragon in the clouds visit 88
night market calm that's 88 night market
calm don't miss your chance the dragon
it can fly away
[Music]